[Musica]
la regista trasformation sembra essere
particolarmente di moda
questo è un grafico stampato pochi
minuti fa da google trends che dice qual
è l'interesse come sta crescendo
l'interesse per questo tema nel tempo
come vedete dal 2014 la curva sale un
bel po e probabilmente la ragione di
tutta questa popolarità risiede nel
fatto che abbiamo capito da un po di
tempo che il digitale aiuta aiuta a
fidelizzare i clienti aiuta ad essere
più efficienti nei processi aiuta a
costruire servizi a maggior valore
aggiunto quindi sul digitale si gioca
una parte importante nella competitività
delle nostre imprese
eppure nelle interviste che mi capita
spesso di fare per i miei progetti di
ricerca con manager e collaboratori
imprenditori imprese private pubbliche
non profit e quando chiedo pensa all
ultimo progetto di trasformazione
digitale l'ultimo progetto in cui ha
implementato lo so gestionale un
software per la contabilità banali sito
web un ecommerce dimmi come è andata la
risposta che assomiglia un po a questa
più o meno la sensazione che vedo
prevalere assomiglia un po a quella del
nostro amico l'ho chiamato giorno non so
se si chiami così però il peso chiamarlo
così
in realtà john non è l'unico ad avere
problemi con la trasformazione digitale
sono quattro su cinque le organizzazioni
che ritengono di non aver intrapreso
completamente un processo di
trasformazione digitale e allora la
domanda particolarmente interessante è
perché è il primo punto il punto da cui
partire è che c'è una grande differenza
fra digitalizzazione e trasformazione
digitale la digitalizzazione quando
aggiungi uno strato tecnologico digitale
del software dei sensori a un processo
di lavoro ok
la trasformazione digitale e quando
cambi il tuo modello di business e il
tuo modello organizzativo a partire
dalle opportunità che ti sono offerte
dal digitale
vi faccio un esempio che secondo me
chiarisce meglio questa differenza
qualche anno fa sono stato chiamato a
fare una ricerca da un'organizzazione
che si occupa di recuperare cibo dalla
filiera agroalimentare e di
ridistribuirlo delle strutture
caritative in tutta italia che poi con
quel cibo preparano dei con quegli
alimenti preparano appunto dei pasti per
delle persone che ne hanno bisogno
in quell'occasione mi è stato chiesto di
immaginare come la tecnologia poteva
cambiare quel tipo di organizzazione e
dopo un po di analisi sono arrivato alla
proposta e ad immaginare un nuovo
modello un modello nel quale il cibo non
veniva più raccolto da banco alimentare
e portato nei magazzini e poi
redistribuito ma scambiato direttamente
fra gli attori della filiera
agroalimentare e le strutture caritative
che ne avevano bisogno quindi la
tecnologia interveniva in una sorta di
disintermediazione ok
quando ho raccontato questo tipo di
situazione è evidente che stavo parlando
di cambiamento cambiamento nelle
competenze richieste cambiamento nel
modello cambiamento nel tipo di attori
coinvolti cambiamento nella percezione
che un'organizzazione a circa il ruolo
che ricopre all'interno di un ecosistema
il cambiamento a uno sgradevole effetto
che da un lato può essere entusiasmante
ma un po ci mette sempre paura no
il cambiamento comporta il comporta una
una dose di ignoto quindi comporta a
fare le cose diversamente da come
abbiamo sempre fatte cambiano a cambiare
significa aver paura di un calo delle
performance nelle aziende finora andata
sempre bene chissà se con una
trasformazione digitale continueremo a
stare sul mercato come abbiamo fatto
finora
la paura è anche quella di non essere
all'altezza chissà se
le competenze che o saranno sufficienti
a cambiare significa in buona sostanza
avere paura che le cose non vadano poi
per il verso giusto cambiare implica
questa paura perché troppo spesso quando
si parla di cambiamento e di
trasformazione lo si fa
immaginando una frattura immaginando una
rottura una discontinuità immaginando
qualcosa di nuovo che subentra al
vecchio immaginando qualcosa di digitale
che subentra qualcosa di analogico e
proprio su questo tema del cambiamento e
della del passaggio del bivio si innesca
un altra retorica un'altra narrazione
che è quella della contrapposizione fra
giovani e meno giovani
e come se i giovani fossero gli unici a
poter portare in qualche modo
cambiamento e trasformazione digitali in
realtà sappiamo che non è così però per
qualche strano motivo nella narrazione
prevalente c'è questa idea allora se
cambiare significa avere paura perché ci
si sente di fronte a questa potenziale
rottura
la domanda che mi faccio e vi faccio è
ma si può avere una trasformazione
digitale che sia più inclusiva cioè che
non comporti questa questa frattura
questa contrapposizione la prima volta
che ho pensato alla trasformazione
digitale inclusiva stato negli stati
uniti io mi trovavo nel national park
service che il sistema di parchi
nazionali americani e stavo facendo la
mia ricerca durante il dottorato di
ricerca e la domanda a cui cercavo di
rispondere e di capire la cosa che
cercavo di capire era come alcuni
ragazzi li vedete giovanissimi potessero
dare un contributo nel proporre idee di
trasformazione digitale che aiutassero i
parchi nazionali ad inglobare un po di
tecnologia al loro interno
li vedete no erano questi ragazzi ea
proponevano un po di progetti che poi
venivano messi a
e condivisi con lo staff e il team del
national park service che era fatto
mediamente persone un po più grandi di
quelle lì il mio ruolo cal era il mio
ruolo era quello di facilitare questa
relazione ok di facilitare l'incontro
fra questi giovani e i saggi del
national park service
in quell'occasione ho proprio costruito
questa idea semplice quanto volete però
estremamente efficace dal mio punto di
vista la trasformazione digitale non
comporta una frattura ed è inclusiva
se viene fatta da un saggio una persona
con esperienza
un giovane che magari ha qualche idea
una propria visione di cosa sia la
trasformazione digitale è un esperto
esterno un facilitatore che faccia
dialogare queste due anima queste due
anime in modo tale che la trasformazione
digitale sia inclusiva e soprattutto
intergenerazionale quest idea dell'inter
del fatto che la trasformazione digitale
possa essere intergenerazionale ha
trovato dopo qualche tempo al mio
ritorno in italia una prima conferma in
questa storia che vi voglio condividere
la storia di danilo lo vedete è la
persona più a sinistra nella foto lo
chiameremo il facilitatore l'esperto
della situazione che ha consentito a suo
papà
la persona al centro della foto ea suo
figlio la persona più a destra di
entrare in un dialogo che ha consentito
all'azienda di famiglia questa
falegnameria toscana di fare un bel
percorso di trasformazione digitale
in quell'occasione ho capito che la
trasformazione digitale è tanto più
inclusiva quanto più è
intergenerazionale da quel momento ho
iniziato a cercare conferme empiriche di
questa idea e quindi ho iniziato a
seguire degli incontri fra imprenditori
con esperienza e start upper ho iniziato
a portare i miei studenti a confrontarsi
con manager di organizzazioni di imprese
del territorio
e non ho intervistato tanti tanti tanti
imprenditori per farmi raccontare casi
nei quali questa trasformazione digitale
inclusiva ed intergenerazionale aveva
avuto luogo
ho partecipato a riunioni come questa
interne di organizzazioni nelle quali i
manager
questa è una multinazionale che lavora
anche ha sede a milano
i manager di queste organizzazioni si
scambiavano opinioni circa come questa
trasformazione digitale inclusiva avesse
luogo
e ho capito che ci sono alcuni fattori
che condizionano più di tutti gli altri
il successo di questo tipo di
trasformazione digitale il dialogo la
relazione e la fiducia
questi tre ingredienti fanno la
differenza fra una trasformazione
digitale inclusiva intergenerazionale e
una trasformazione digitale che al più
sarà digitalizzazione oppure che
comporterà una frattura
allora da dove si può iniziare dove le
imprese e le organizzazioni pubbliche
non profit possono partire per fare
questo percorso di trasformazione
digitale inclusivo ed intergenerazionale
si può partire dall interno dell
organizzazione come in questo caso in
questa slide vedete una una persona col
si chiama vedete qui che tutto sommato
non sta troppo su in termini di livello
gerarchico nell'organizzazione ma che è
quello che io chiamo un digital tiro un
eroe digitale qualcuno che per
caratteristiche personali ha una visione
circa la direzione in termini di
trasformazione digitale che può essere
presa dal dall impresa trovare col nelle
organizzazioni significa trovare quella
persona che lo vedete a destra occupa
una posizione centrale
quando si parla di capire in quale
direzione portare la nostra
organizzazione in termini di
trasformazione digitale
oggi abbiamo a disposizione strumenti
anche abbastanza curati per misurare le
competenze digitali delle persone questo
modello che abbiamo sviluppato negli
ultimi 12 mesi in team di ricerca che ci
consente di veramente misurare con una
certa accuratezza chi nelle
organizzazioni è un digital tiro quindi
partire dalla dall'individuare un eroe
digitale nella nostra organizzazione può
essere un primo modo per avviare un
percorso di trasformazione digitale
inclusivo un'altra un'altra occasione e
un'altra opportunità è quella di cercare
nelle tante start up che si stanno
sviluppando un po in giro nel paese la
nostra università è ricca di questo tipo
di organizzazioni e gli start upper
hanno due grandi bisogni il primo è
quello di validare la loro idea di
business non sanno se la loro idea su
cui stanno costruendo la
l'organizzazione avrà successo oppure no
e la seconda molto più semplice avere
almeno un cliente
le imprese possono trovare nella
relazione con queste start up
un'occasione nuova importante di fare
trasformazione digitale
a patto che persista quella triade che
vi ho fatto vedere prima il saggio il
giovane l'esperto che facilita questa
relazione
io mi sento di chiudere con con questa
frase e che poi riassume un po il senso
come si fa a costruire relazioni basate
sulla fiducia e sul dialogo per
sviluppare percorsi di trasformazione
digitale inclusiva ed intergenerazionale
e la verità è che c'è bisogno di maestri
ho pensato tanto a quale immagine
utilizzare per condividere con voi quale
secondo me l'idea di maestro ci ho
pensato molto e alla fine non l'ho
trovata però poi mi è venuta in mente
un'immagine di me piccolino sulle gambe
di mio nonno mentre guida il trattore
mio nonno me lo immaginavo un po così
questa non è un'immagine reale di suo
nonno ma è proprio questa l'immagine che
c'è nella mia
testa mio nonno che mi tiene sulle sue
gambe e pur mantenendo il controllo del
trattore perché io non arrivava nemmeno
i pedali del freno
mi dà la possibilità di tenere in mano
la leva e le leve per spostare il
trattore nella direzione che più mi
piace andando a costruire questa
relazione fra saggio mio nonno è giovane
con il desiderio di fare innovazione di
portare un pò l'impresa di famiglia
nella direzione auspicata mancava un
personaggio
se avete seguito un po nel percorso
manca l'esperto esterno manca quella
persona che possa facilitare
probabilmente anche se cercassi nell
album di famiglia non troverei alcuna
foto con lei ma nel mio caso l'esperto
in questione mia nonna me la immagino in
una foto del genere un po fuori no dal
dal riquadro mia nonna è quella persona
che riesce per caratteristiche personali
per una certa capacità di empatica per
la profonda conoscenza dei processi in
questione riesce a dialogare sia con il
saggio che con il giovane ea farli
ritrovare nella costruzione di un
percorso di trasformazione digitale che
sia inclusivo intergenerazionale e
soprattutto utile per aiutare le imprese
del nostro paese a crescere grazie mille
[Applauso]